what did you see in like first of all
how did you actually find Jack Harlow
because all these like old videos of him
being 12 and rapping like went viral
like like a year or two ago and it was
just so funny oh this little
[__] was rapping when he was a
child yeah how did you like actually
like discover a kid a little white dude
by all means kind of a little nerdy dude
in in Louisville so I had a homeboy come
to the studio one day and just say his
name to me
and I went on Instagram and just like
immediately followed him and Jack saw me
follow him and he like followed me back
and he he wound up later telling me like
he told his homeboy like yo DJ Drama
just followed me like Damn signed the
drum and there's a very legendary
engineer that we've worked with
um throughout my career who's uh mixed
uh a bunch of my records as well as a
lot of Classics including Dreams and
Nightmares worked with Waka worked with
um Two Chains his name is ky ky
engineering so yeah he has you know KY
engineering he's got a great tag yeah so
his name is ky because he's from
Kentucky and
um around the same time that I had found
out about Jack he was also uh working
with Jack and he told Lake like yo I got
something I want to bring to you you
know I just want to get it to a certain
space so he was you know he was putting
a bug in Lake's ear about Jack so it
kind of like literally happened around
the same time and then Jack just one one
day found his way to main streets and
then you know I heard he was in the
building and we like we met and we sat
down and we chopped it up we talked
music and life and movies and [__] like
that and you know I was I was just
impressed and then you know we came to
the table like you know we had a meeting
and uh all parties you know came to the
agreement that we want to design them
it's crazy too because I do feel like
you guys have kind of gone the old
school route of like actually developing
artists yeah that's how we like to do it
we like to get
involved like in the early stage of the
their career and like you know be part
of artist development yeah nobody's
doing that like like I remember like
Jack was just on Like These Little Indie
tours dropping shot dark night when we
signed them so it's kind of crazy like
yeah in an era where everybody's signing
[__] because it's it's viral you
guys have kind of taken the opposite
approach and reaped the benefits I mean
it's it's paid off like we have you know
we have generational artists like we
have [__] Superstars you know what
I'm saying so you know like we were
talking it's it's quality over quantity
you know and and then there are times
when to be honest with within us
ourselves as a label like
we we discuss and like analyze like
about signing more you know more more
quantity than we we might do at the
level we are now so
um but you know when we when we signed
something like we really believe in it
and you know we we put that time in and
our artists are like you know artists
that are gonna be here you know what I'm
saying did you guys ever try to sign
estg
um we did and so that so you guys are
part of that whole was it like a bidding
war or no the to be honest
um Lake and um one of our anar's Royce
Monroe uh Royce was
was
um pretty much uh engineering estg he
did a lot of his early stuff at mean
streets and he was he was in the
building like all the time the entire
time and
um Lake also wanted to sign EST to the
label the way we were trying to go
around to structure the deal
um
wasn't exactly what estg was looking for
at the time
and the way not Nigel shot the Nigel you
know Nodge was who was uh a r at
Atlantic at a time you know used to be a
mean streets all the time he came to
Mean Streets met G and went and took him
to Gotti so that's how it happened yeah
and then there's like the legendary
video of yo got yeah I feel like anytime
you sign with CMG you just get a pile of
cash yeah like a big ass chain and cash
and all that so you know I mean
everything happens for a reason you know
um I can't front like G is definitely
somebody that like for me I'm like damn
we I wish yeah yeah yeah for sure does
anybody else who was like kind of like
at the finish line but just didn't for
whatever reason ended up working out
they made a choice to go somewhere else
or
um yeah there's people there's there's
there's various people like you know uh
early on we were we were interested in
signing Tory Lanez
um
who else was there you know we were I
was
I was there early on in Amigo's career
um um OT Genesis
OT yeah yeah we wanted to sign OT
um
you know what you guys we won the sign
problem
you guys you guys had scheme we asking
yes game's still Generation Now shout
out to my guy scheme the Duke man was
the scheme are first yeah it's the first
person we ever signed let's go scheme
yep
scheme
are you guys actively always trying to
sign artists because that's all you have
you do have a roster of artists that you
are develop I mean there's a guy like
Sadie Hendrix who's just been kind of
just putting in that grind and just
continuously staying consistent leveling
up slowly you know what I'm saying
putting out Quality Music Sunny digital
Sunny digital I didn't know Sunny
digital was yeah Sunny digital
generation now
um he has a project coming out we have a
female artist carvina
um that we've been developing uh she's
super fire and then we have some we have
some new artists you guys gotta grab
someone from LA
yeah
I'm from Detroit
and Detroit I feel like Detroit's you
got to get somebody from Detroit bruh
yeah I'm open listen
it hit my line don't let y'all sign baby
Tron away from Ghazi hit my line and we
um we have um we're we're in the process
of uh rebooting the management company
on generation now too so we got some
some dope uh some some dope people on
the roster too that we're gonna announce
soon